bonjour et bienvenue dans reporter
l'émission de grands reportages de la
rédaction de france 24 cette semaine
nous nous intéressons à un phénomène
politique qui parcourt l'europe la
montée des extrêmes droites une extrême
droite décomplexée faisant fi de
l'histoire et c'est peut-être ce qui
peut surprendre très jeune céline
schmitt bonjour vous avez réalisé ce
reportage on l'a vu lors des élections
présidentielles en france l'extrême
droite attire principalement les jeunes
entre 25 et 35 ans une tendance que l'on
retrouve un peu partout en europe alors
pourquoi vous êtes vous focalisez en
particulier sur ces trois pays
l'allemagne l'italie et l'espagne
alors oui effectivement vous venez de le
dire les jeunes ont été nombreux à voter
pour l'extrême droite en france nous
avons donc souhaité savoir si cette
tendance est bien se confirme en italie
en espagne et en allemagne des pays
voisins de la france et qui ont connu
des dictatures d'extrême droite des pays
qui sont aussi très intéressant parce
que l'extrême droite y est représentée
par des partis qui sont très jeunes
fratelli d'italia vox et l'afd sont des
partis qui ont moins de dix ans
d'existence mais qui rivalise déjà avec
les grands partis traditionnels
nous avons donc souhaité comprendre les
ressorts de ce vote et qui ce qui séduit
les jeunes dans les idées et le
programme de l'extrême droite merci
céline et je vous propose maintenant de
regarder votre reportage on se retrouve
juste après europe à droite toute un
document signé céline schmitt armelle
esposito and my est louise mâle noir et
lorenza penza
[Musique]
non alejandro sanchez marie thérèse
kaiser fabrizio bousnane mots sont les
nouveaux visages de l'extrême droite
dans leur pays ils n'ont pas trente cinq
ans aujourd'hui chacun à leur manière
ils se sont affranchis du passé et
milite de manière décomplexée au sein de
jeunes partis vox l'afd et fratelli
d'italia aux moins de 10 ans
[Musique]
nous sommes à berlin au bundestag marie
thérèse kaiser est assistante
parlementaire à 25 ans cet ancien
mannequin est l'une des stars des
réseaux sociaux de l'afd le jeune parti
d'extrême droite allemand
sur mon compte à fdg des contenus qu'ils
respectent la charte graphique du parti
et je publie des contenus sur des sujets
d'actualité
elle défend par exemple une certaine
idée de la femme
toutefois avant de commencer le plus
important je suis féminine mais pas
féministe
effrayés par l'arrivée des migrants en
allemagne elle s'est engagée à l'afd en
2017 sur instagram elle s'adresse
aujourd'hui aux jeunes et rafraîchit
l'image de l'extrême droite
depuis que j'ai c'est réfléchir je
travaille comme modèle pour des marques
et dans la gastronomie je sais donc trop
bien ce que c'est et à quel point il est
dur de gagner chaque centime
une stratégie qui s'inscrit dans l'adn
du parti
avec les médias traditionnels nous
n'étions pas représentés comme nous le
souhaitions du coup nous nous sommes
rabattus sur les réseaux sociaux et cela
nous permet de communiquer directement
avec les gens
on peut rétrécir mon front et mon menton
et on peut aussi à grandir mes yeux mais
l'engagement de marie thérèse à ses
conséquences
ici c'est chez mes parents et comme vous
voyez ma maison a été taguée cette nuit
d'inscription antinazi le discours ultra
identitaire de l'afd en allemagne ravive
les traumatismes du passé
des réactions qu'elle juge anachronique
les allemands ont un complexe de
culpabilité hérités de l'histoire se la
joue un rôle dans la diabolisation de
l'afd comme sommes le seul parti
d'opposition qui représente vraiment les
valeurs de l'allemagne et qui souhaitent
préserver ses particularités
[Musique]
jean-pascal homme est également l'un des
nouveaux visages de l'afd dans sa ville
à cottbus il s'est fait connaître en
organisant chaque lundi des
manifestations anti migrants puis contre
les mesures sanitaires
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans la rue
parce que nous ne voulons pas
d'obligation vaccinale alors marchons
avec détermination mais paisiblement je
vous remercie d'être là
[Applaudissements]
jean pascal a trouvé dans la pandémie le
moyen de gagner en popularité
un glissement stratégiques nécessaires
le sentiment anti migrants est devenu
moins porteur politiquement
je me suis rendu compte que c'est un
sujet qui préoccupe les gens ils ont
commencé à sortir dans la rue et moi
même à un moment je me suis dit stop ça
va trop loin alors on s'est organisé
pour protester contre la violation des
droits fondamentaux que nous subissons
depuis des mois
un choix qui fait mouche l'ancien
adolescents séduit par l'extrême droite
rassemble aujourd'hui au delà du parti
[Musique]
cette manifestation ce n'est pas que
l'afd c'est tout le monde ça n'a rien à
voir avec une question les partis
politiques d'ailleurs moi je me suis
même pas membre de l'afd
[Musique]
nous sommes à rome dans le quartier de
l'est ou reconstruits par mussolini dans
les années 30
un lieu qu'affectionne particulièrement
ses militants de fratelli d'italia
[Musique]
la hausse de la facture d'électricité
est insoutenable pour les foyers elles
pèsent sur les familles elle pèse aussi
sur les entreprises ça affaiblit notre
économie
fabrizio bousnane go est un meneur de
troupe militant de la première heure il
est en campagne permanente sur le
terrain sont laïques motifs défendre le
pouvoir d'achat
il ya eu des petites z mais elles ne
suffisent clairement pas à réduire les
dépenses les gens n'arrivent pas à
boucler les fins de mois sur une année
ce sont des milliers d'euros à payer en
plus pour les familles wim chiomento
fournier familiale fabrizio incarne le
nouveau visage de l'extrême droite
italienne mais dans ses rangs difficile
d'effacer certains vieux réflexes
hérités du fascisme
salut alfredo ouais je suis avec france
24 la wii sont là oui
une fois notre caméra éloigné leçon
continue
malgré ses anciens réflexes fabrizio
tente de transmettre cette nouvelle
image au plus jeune des militants comme
nicolas étudiant
je peux vous donner un fire non merci
il y à des personnes qui le prennent
sans problème d'autres à qui je dois
expliquer ce qu'on fait est certain en
revanche qui voit notre logo et ne
veulent rien savoir
trois générations après la chute du
dictateur mussolini comme lui certains
jeunes n'ont pas honte de leur héritage
venez au mans sur l'aîné de
benito mussolini de ce que j'en ai
appris a permis les premières maisons
populaire à éviter que des gens vivent
dans la rue
il a mis à l'abri des personnes qui ne
pouvaient pas s'offrir un toit
il est aussi fait des choses affreuses
disons que personne n'est parfait
cette distanciation avec le passé
fabrizio la revendique ce matin il
retrouve david et un collègue de travail
qu'il tente de recruter
un jour me voilà david salut comment vas
tu ça va bien j'étais en train de
regarder le journal
mccain fratelli est un parti vraiment de
droit mais une droite qui n'a rien à
voir avec le passé
c'est une droite moderne sait capable
aujourd'hui de gouverner et moderne
annoncera qu'elle
est
avec eux on parle de la patrie c'est un
parti nationaliste identitaire de
religion chrétienne
est donc ce sont les fondamentaux du
parti shas et moi ça me convient parce
que je les partage
ce discours parfaitement dosé a permis à
fratelli d'italia d'être crédité de plus
de 20% des intentions de vote aux
prochaines élections
en espagne un parti est parvenu à
décomplexer le vote d'extrême droite
vox à moins de 10 ans d'existence mais
il est déjà la troisième force politique
du pays
juan petit est avocat spécialisé en
droit du travail
asseyez vous voulez depuis près d'un an
juan travail chez solidaridad le
syndicat de vox aujourd'hui il défend
deux agents de sécurité
les patrons ils font vraiment ce qu'ils
veulent
ça ne devrait pas exister mais en
pratique ils le font
ici roanne a trouvé le moyen de défendre
ses valeurs
alors que là d'un cas d'un j'ai appris
ma carte je t'envoie tous les documents
demain
à l'essec est
clairement les syndicats traditionnels
ont abandonné les travailleurs on a en
effet sida et dans le maine ils se sont
retrouvés sans protection et ça crée des
besoins énormes
c'est pour ça que solidaridad est arrivé
et par l'effort pas la choisira sur le
talent est là avec un discours social
vox séduit de plus en plus d'électeurs
le parti cible l'espagne qui se lèvent
tôt pour se référer vox s'adresse
directement à pas aux élites ou aux
grandes fortunes comme le pensent
certains
solidaridad a déjà convaincu treize
mille salariés espagnols
et alejandro est ce que tu as à
constituer des sections syndicales
d'innergex à malaga la corogne
guadalajara et séville oui c'est bon
alejandro à 24 ans il s'occupe de la
communication du syndicat à travers ses
publications sur les réseaux sociaux il
transmet une certaine image de l'espagne
nous nous adressons aux gens de manière
normale avec un langage que tout le
monde comprend nous parlons de valeurs
qui sont naturels
comme par exemple la défense de la
nation
la nation
[Musique]
une vision qu'il porte au delà des murs
du syndicat
aujourd'hui des milliers de
transporteurs routiers manifestent
contre la hausse des prix du carburant
pour alejandro erwan c'est l'occasion de
se faire remarquer
[Applaudissements]
salua les rendements ya du monde et pas
un seul drapeau lui j'étais ou des
communistes
le syndicat tente de séduire les déçus
du gouvernement socialiste
bonjour comment ça va pourquoi vous êtes
ici qu'est ce que vous revendiquez
parce qu'on a plus de quoi manger j'ai
même dû mettre mon camion avant
[Musique]
notre raison d'être c'est de soutenir
les travailleurs parce qu'on pense que
c'est ce qui est juste mais c'est
évident que ce qu'on veut c'est que le
gouvernement quitte le pouvoir le plus
vite possible et si ces manifestations
internet et bien c'est tant mieux
et les représentants politiques de vox
sont prêts aux côtés de l'espagne qui se
lèvent tôt ces députés défendent plus de
souveraineté
le problème c'est que la globalisation
ruines des économies nationales avec
solidaridad en à un syndicat qui n'est
pas un syndicat de classe au contraire
il défend la réindustrialisation et la
reconstruction de l'espagne au final
c'est sa seule une espagne forte peut
vraiment défendre ses travailleurs
en italie en allemagne en espagne
c'est nouveau visage de l'extrême droite
ont permis alors partis nationaux de se
placer aujourd'hui aux portes du pouvoir
on comprend en regardant ce document le
rôle primordial que jouent les réseaux
sociaux dans le succès de ces partis
d'extrême droite céline c'est ça leur
force par rapport aux partis
traditionnels
effectivement ce que nous avons tous
constaté bien c'est que ces jeunes
partis sont particulièrement performants
sur les réseaux sociaux une performance
qui s'explique de leurs aveux par une
nécessité ils disent tous ne pas se
sentir représentés correctement par les
médias traditionnels
il confie et bien que les médias
traditionnels véhicules parfois une
image erronée voire caricatural de leurs
idées ça a d'ailleurs été une difficulté
pour nous puisqu'il a fallu dépasser
cette méfiance pour pouvoir accéder à
ces partis et tourner ce reportage plus
globalement ils investissent les réseaux
sociaux mais surtout ils ont réussi et
bien à s'approprier les codes de ces
canaux par exemple et bien en créant des
des des chaînes qui sont
particulièrement adressé à la jeunesse
des contenus donc dans lesquelles il
s'exprime avec un langage qui est très
simple ils proposent parfois d'ailleurs
déconvenue humoristique pour finalement
et bien attirer de plus en plus
d'abonnés et on le voit dans les
chiffres c'est une stratégie qui marche
par exemple lorsqu'on regarde lève des
sur facebook et bien ils ont deux fois
plus d'abonnés que les grands partis
traditionnels allemands et lorsqu'on
regarde par exemple vox en espagne et
bien sûr leurs chaînes sur leur sur leur
canal d'instagram eh bien ils ont six
cent cinquante mille abonnés lorsque le
parti socialiste au pouvoir le peso et
n'en compte que 119 me
tous ont en commun une certaine
fascination pour la russie et pour
poutine la guerre en ukraine
pourrait-elle changer l'image de ces
partis avoir un impact négatif sur les
opinions publiques
eh bien c'est la question que tout le
monde se posent les observateurs
ils ont tous effectivement souligné le
fait que l'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie oblige les partis d'extrême
droite à reformuler leur positionnement
en vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine et de
la russie en tout cas nous ce que l'on a
constaté sur le terrain est bien c'est
que les partis ont tous souhaité se
distancer de vladimir poutine je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter et bien une
réponse de feu de fabricio bousnane go
de fret et lead italia qui s'exprimait
au micro de notre équipe en italie
beaucoup pensent qu'un parti comme le
nôtre flatté lee d'italia pourrait
soutenir poutine et la russie ou d'aussi
gros ça il n'y a rien de plus faux que
cela en réalité dès le début il ya eu
une position claire adoptée par les
cadres du parti sur la question
ukrainienne
d'ailleurs en ce moment et nous menons
des actions politiques sur le terrain
dans ce sens
collectons des biens de première
nécessité des médicaments pour le peuple
kényan pour aider la population civile
riman qui est évidemment la première
victime de ce conflit militaire
ce que nous avons tous constaté sur le
terrain est bien c'est que c'est parti
ces jeunes partis d'extrême droite se
distance donc de vladimir poutine ils
condamnent tous unanimement l'invasion
de l'ukraine en revanche là où il ya
quelques différences qui se font jour
c'est que certains partis et là je pense
particulièrement à l'afd et la cheffe de
l'afd au bundestag est bien temps d'une
certaine manière de justifier la
réaction de vladimir poutine en parlant
d'ailleurs d'un échec historique de
l'europe occidentale qui a entretenu
finalement des perspectives d'adhésion
pour l'ukraine à l'otan ce qui justement
au niveau de vladimir poutine et bien
créer le sentiment est bien que son
statut de puissance dans la région était
une certaine manière remis en question
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'effectivement est bien la conséquence
de l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
pourrait avoir des conséquences mais
celle là on les verra évidemment que
dans le futur
merci céline pour cet éclairage et bien
sûr pour ce reportage je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter le magazine
de grands reportages de la rédaction de
france 24
[Musique]